We are so mean to ourselves.
So utterly, barbarically cruel.
If we saw someone treating a stranger the
way we tend to treat ourselves, we’d be
appalled.
We need to learn to be that most rare of things:
a proper friend to ourselves. To be our own
best friend.
-- It doesn’t come naturally; we need to
practice saying some of the following to ourselves:
You deserve to exist;
it's OK to make mistakes;
you can be forgiven;
I know how hard you try
and all the obstacles you’ve had to overcome
I don't care what the others think;
you can be weak with me;
you can mess up
You can fall apart.
You can be imperfect;
You can let me down.
I’m on your side: I’m touched by how much
effort you have made and how deeply you have
suffered.
You don't have to prove yourself to me;
I don't need you to 'be' somebody…
I can love you as you are - despite everything.
I’m your best friend.
Always
And I’m right here.
Small Pleasures, guides us around the best of life’s overlooked or underestimated pleasures, to find out more, follow the link on your screen now.